street fighter 5 launched with 16
characters and only a handful of modes
but March seems to be the month when
Capcom will start to turn things around
new modes and the game's first dlc
character are on their way and capcom
has revealed a bunch of new details
first up the developer released several
screenshots of Alex he first appeared in
Street Fighter 3 and he's still very
much a grappling character Capcom has
plenty of details on his moveset on the
unity blog he'll be joined by five more
DLC characters over the next few months
additionally we're finally getting a
challenge mode packed with tutorials
that will help you learn different
characters at various skill levels
online rematches in the in-game shop are
also coming with the update +
improvements to the battle lounge and
character balance there's no set release
date for Alex or the big update yet but
it's definitely coming in March and
don't forget the true story mode is also
on its way in June whenever Capcom
announces more we'll tell you all about
it at gamespot I'm Tony you can follow
me on twitter at chain-gun Pope and I
need to go practice some critical arts